hey guys it's desi founder thing here
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of agents of shield
episode 15 yes men so this is the ones
guest starring jamie alexander to save
the show head back to the top of the
ratings well apparently got a ratings
bump because everyone wanted to see sit
right you know this door connection
Asgardian connection i had to say in
terms of the story wise and the quality
of the show when we're talking about the
the previous couple episodes that was a
half a step forward there's two steps
back see I actually like this one down
this guy gets old by the mark I just
like jaimie alexander so my I like her a
lot you know I recognize that this is a
crutch because the rest of the seasons
not going to like this we're not I mean
if the show gets were new if it does
maybe we'll see her in one episode in
the future but this is not like the
direction the show is going to be in but
because she was in it because I came
from the extras name but the one to play
Lorelai for magic city was in it I like
this episode i love the conversation
between Linda Mae and SIF about like
knowing what it's like to not be able to
have a man that you want because she
understands what that is like fourth or
I liked all those connections I like the
fact that the end of the episode if she
was like yeah um you know Odin once
Lorelei back and Asgard but we know Odin
is not Odin only lochia so Loki wants
her back and ask are we gonna see her
again this is just enough I don't know
what that means like that sort of
interested me what upsets me is that I
know we're probably not gonna see this
again this is like a one-time thing it's
like a one-shot a comic books like a
one-shot so but i think david has been
fooled I'm sorry I market you tomorrow
maybe she did say i love GTA Xander too
I think his greatest if not a good
episode for my opinion I watching it and
I really want I calamity connected to
the Cinematic Universe so yeah for me it
was not a good episode i thought you
know i think you're blinded by the two
hot women that were on the show happens
to me it's like with almost human sex
bots is still the best episode yet happy
XO for me like i was like
first of all I'd you know I just didn't
like Lorelei's is the villain you know
the whole seducing the man thing I know
it's from the comic books and everything
it just came off cheesy for the show I
felt like the last two episodes have
been a step up in the quality and and
doing an overall sorta yes there were
some cool things yeah you know the tying
with Thor and also the whole Nick Fury
not Nick Fury a call Agent Coulson
talking about possibly the Kree I mean
sift dropping about all the ball the
blue different kind of blue alias she's
met over time yeah yeah and she
mentioned the curry which we talked
about in the last episode so it's
possibly gonna be the Kree cuz that's
the most well-known of alien races that
she mentioned and it's the one that they
have the rights to still yes they don't
have the rights to the scrolls or
anything else and the schools are green
anyways but yeah just for me it just
didn't work just didn't work and I like
that when i say i liked it i said i
enjoyed it was enjoyable i still don't
really like this series that much for
this episode compared to the rest of
them was more enjoyable even with the
one like said last week bill paxton and
i actually enjoyed this one more really
i like it's probably the marketing it's
if it's Asgard to come to a vc so i late
they sold me yeah i liked last episodes
better and the one before that even more
so oh yeah this one you know there was
the tie in at the end in terms of I
don't know why agent coulson felt the
need that he had to tell sky of all
people about about the whole because no
one else knows about yeah about the
alien that he found then for some reason
tell sky and now we know that where's
Melinda may is like welcome to and
Melinda may is not really and she did
that on purpose cuz she wants she wanted
him to reveal it so that she would know
she's kind of like a double agent she's
probably working for Nick Fury directly
he knows Coulson's yeah I don't think
she's a double agent in terms of she's a
bad guy no I think she's a double agent
within shield and Nick Fury or whoever
helped me Bill Paxton right character
yeah maybe he works for him she works
for somebody else that she's really an
even like you in the event
sures like Tony Stark in the Avengers
said like he doesn't trust you know he
doesn't trust fury said his spies have
spies you know so I mean he is an agent
that's what he you know he's a spy but I
mean there's some good moments like I
did I don't know why you know a grant
would want to go for sky over me
personally this is me I would go for me
but anyway yeah I was there were some
good moments but again I just know this
is not going to continue this is not
gonna be the future of this show we're
not going to get more jaimie alexander i
mean if the show even gets renewed so it
was a nice taste of what maybe could
have been with the show could have been
i think it's too late for the show to
get its fans back i think we can shed
people tuned in they want to see what's
gonna happen by think that's gonna be it
you know yeah because there's not gonna
be well first of all they're skipping
next week right ya doing some marvel
cinematic universe like oh look up the
future like so there you go you take any
type of momentum gone the scheduling is
really i mean i'm not saying like this
some fantastic show that everyone should
be watching but they're not helping now
no no it's a shoot themselves in the
foot so i mean this this was a taste of
what maybe could have been with the
series but it's it's too late how do you
like the one I want to be sons of
anarchy in the beginning that was bad
yeah you know we're gonna do a
motorcycle gang if you realize you're
going up against sons of anarchy doubt
that was pretty late like I was like
he's my motor starter that's a 19 you
know it's like come on man like it was
just yeah that the show still it's still
agents of shield yeah even with jaimie
alexander alright guys so that's what we
thought the episode are you with me
thinking that it wasn't that great and
even with the weight with the guest star
of a jaimie alexander whose fantastic
brings a show up to an a are you with
david blinded by the marketing blinded
by the gas yes ABC and any really
enjoyed the episode let us know in the
comments section below on our website
thing CARICOM or on our youtube channel
think hero pro make sure to subscribe to
that you also find us on twitter you
know let me know like david this is the
best episode of agents of shield yet
because of jaimie alexander i didn't buy
this at think hero i'm at griffin de and
we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans and
make sure you like that page and share
our videos on Twitter and Facebook that
would really help us out thanks
you